ті інструменти йди ти забув і своїм
рукам з підручних матеріалів так і
назвати чайний майстер класу тут ми за
дівкою проводити музиканти
симфонічного берлінського оркестру
радіо
він esp одягаються відліку закінченим
чи український ти хоча б на два ти ж не
зможе турботи праві ну та зі склянкою
багатими
приділив похмурий якщо у зовсім і нижчому
вимили змінності нею критичну
ситуації я кімоно і перебувають у будинку
після другої найголовніші їй страху
виживання та мета страх щодо креативний
просто на моїй годині і я вірю в чому і
кошти можна дзвенить і душа вести
зеленими хенками
ідея проекту накласти мари не бандос у
польше скрипт симфонічного оркестру
берлінського радіо в вона родом з України
ібери чому звичайно терапія можна зменшити
і дітей лікувати відриву ви адже edit
елементарно вид потягнути вигляд бомбарду
ваняють йому рахунок тут майже всі
задіяні про кидає піпетка але
надується ціна i quit канонаду яку там
була в день вмістити в ти снаряди на
снаряди
13 річкові павла про рік я їх взаємного
руку два місяці встиг вчасно весь вигляд
бувало обстріли житлових кварталів біля
нашого будинку мільйона шубу будинку впав
снаряд
град з хлодвіг він повипадало ми з того
там біля тремтіння по біглоу підвал
бобул він бо страшно за blu на та страж
ніші для мін цей м'яз пораниш абелю
будинку нападала снарядами подавалась
снарядів де це за дівка здається ще
коліван і займаються музику і їм дається
за but is весь страх і провину нині павлів
життя туничка спецназ бути
дошкуляти дружин і дітей на автобусі
саду artcool і ніч волонтер із зони ато
три ти ж не бог у полонія з апарату
стив вин знаючи я клина ламаючи психіку
людей особливо його маленьких учора пролітав
ярд ель чорро пролітали так винний позов
зверху над звуком великих дітей
подумав і порахував і ти дура для ten град
мета системи залпового вогню почав їх у
офісу
був він та тугіше прямо на cd погляд на
це дивитися організатори проекту сп
одягаються право сорому не матч інший я
камова більше українських дітей травма
ван їх виною